so today we're going to look at the
seven early signs of kidney
disease there's actually five stages
that the kidney
could potentially go through very mild
to very
severe when you start to reach the level
of
four or five you have to avoid
certain things in your diet big time
like you have to avoid potassium
phosphorous and there's quite a few
other ones but what's interesting is
that potassium has a protective
effect on the kidney but when there's a
certain point where it's gone too far
the body can't handle it and you want to
avoid potassium
all right let's take a look at the seven
early signs of kidney disease
the first one would be a metallic taste
in your mouth
or you your breath smells like ammonia
and because the kidney is a filter it's
like an oil filter
things are backing up and it's coming
out of the breath it's coming out of the
mouth you're tasting certain things that
you shouldn't taste
number two you have protein aversion you
have a great
dislike of protein especially meat
number three you're nauseous or
you're vomiting number four difficulty
with
concentration and number five you have
itchiness number six a loss of appetite
number seven your face is swollen your
feet are swollen and even your hands
have edema and their swelling because
the kidney has millions of tiny little
filters okay the blood goes through and
then it actually recycles a lot of
things
and it gets rid of the waste one of the
best
indicators of kidney dysfunction
whether it's one two three four five
would be to
check the gfr it stands for glomerular
filtration rate this is a measurement of
how well the kidney is acting as a
filter
and one of the ways they look at this
value is they look at the creatine of
the blood and creatine is a type of
protein
also if you have protein in the urine or
you have high
bun blood urea nitrogen and this is a
in a blood test and one of the biggest
causes of kidney damage is
being a diabetic or pre-diabetic because
the years of chronic consumption of
refined carbohydrates
junk foods can all cause kidney
destruction
if your glucose is on the high end
that's called glucose toxicity
what happens is that that starts
damaging the tiny filtration units in
the kidney
the blood vessels of the retina of the
eye
destruction of the internal layer of the
coronary artery on the heart
as well as the distal nerves which is
the nerves at the very
end of the toes of the bottom of the
feet or the hands
so you're getting destruction of the
capillaries which is starving off
nutrients to the nerves but the kidney
is definitely
one area that this high level of sugar
destroys
so of course what i would recommend
regardless of what stage the person is
at would be to get on a healthy keto
plan
immediately of course if you're stage
five you're gonna have to make some
adjustments with
certain um nutrients like potassium and
phosphorus but the combination of
intermittent fasting with healthy keto
with other things as well like this is a
really really good
herb that has been shown to decrease
creatine to improve the filtration rate
of the kidneys and i'll put
a link down below to show some
incredible
hardcore data on the benefits of
astragalus
on the kidney it's extremely potent in
helping to reverse
kidney damage all right thanks for
watching